hello everybody welcome to
our last session on
2020. yesterday we had the last
twitch well i had the last twitch stream
today i'm coming the last
oops my bad youtube stream of the
year so it should be pretty fun um well
so definitely our last test on
psychology for the year
i don't know maybe something happens and
i show up on youtube or twitch for you
again
but for right now let's just go ahead
and get started i
am seeing the chat it seems pretty hyped
that's great
um so getting a lot of ads all right so
over the weekend i played for um
i played in the europeans woman club cup
championship uh online obviously and
i played for england because my brother
is in england and
i am very friendly with the team manager
that my brother has
such a great person and so we played i
think there were a lot of different like
i was buying from us there was another
player playing from
um china and like the time zones are
really funny
so like the first round for me i would
have to wake up at six
prepare a little get my brain to work so
i didn't actually play the first round
of
both days i i got the rest and the other
teammates
played which they played beautifully as
well so
um for me however i played five games in
total
and i got four out of five i lost my
first
first game that i played oh i see
the chat is hyping up hi brian hi peter
hi steve all right so um
let's see i to be fair i already did
talk about some of these games on our
two channel but
something that i did is i went back and
i looked at what i should have done for
the openings
and that is something that i will
mention much deeper just
in some of the games that might look a
little
too familiar so um
also also oh where am i i'm a
i'm not on my usual place but i'll be
back next time
just like uh i do not have my onto a
channel
well technically i have an account but i
don't stream
especially because it's kind of a um
it takes a lot of time and dedication
uh-oh
getting a text from tracy also peachy is
really
jumping and exploring around i don't
know if you'll join us
but all right so um
i kind of wanted to go ahead and ask is
there anybody from ukraine here
because my opponent is a very great
ukrainian player who did whoop me pretty
nicely
so just double checking that
anybody let's see
well i mean um not exactly steve i mean
i have
i i only stream with the clubs account
so
that's the only streaming i will be
doing
oh i think i did play someone from
poland too
ah there was nobody from india here all
right
so in this game let's just go ahead and
get started and see how i got hooked
so um one thing that we could look at
is oh sorry camera glitch
sorry trying to clean it okay also i
glitch sorry for the
camera being there's a sorry
okay anyways um so one thing that we
could
look at is no that was not pc
he she wanted to go out but that wasn't
the problem
my eye was sorry um
yeah okay let's just go ahead
and move on from our camera
10 second incidents so
anybody here plays french because french
is a great opening
for both and white and black i generally
like playing against it
but in this specific game i
didn't really have the best experience
to put it slightly
so she played my slide of 6 bishop g5
take take and here i started to
make a little bit mistakes because the
one thing i knew uh
going in was that well about this
opening was that if i could have this
bishop on e4 like
if i can't have my bishop in this
diagonal it's gonna be pretty great why
because my opponent wants to have his
bishop in that diagonal
so that was one of the things i really
did want to
try however
i made a small move
move order issue so i want to ask you
guys so here
why is to move what do you think we
should we could do and julian and peter
um
it really depends on how you play it and
which line you're facing
most lines could be boring most lines
could be very exciting so it kind of
really depends
so what have here white to move
i need a twitch guys the only thing i do
when i have a twitch account
if i had one and if i was streaming was
sit here and study
that would actually probably benefit me
because i would have to study a little
bit more because
today this week is my physics week and
for learning physics i'm going through
the book i'm looking at the videos
and somehow today middle of reading the
book
i was on a couch the cat was up here the
dog was down there
and um he she simply just
was so cute that i fell asleep for about
half an hour
and by the time i woke up i was already
like had other
arrangements that i had to deal with i
am a woman grandmaster an international
master
so there is a there is a slight
difference between the gm and wgm
no uh that was i i don't know why they
didn't make that specification but oh
i'm glad mohammed
you read that that was a that's great
i'm glad you did
i actually still have to find an issue
of it
alright so
i agree so there was no suggestion of
knight f3 that is actually
the move i did in the game however this
is not exactly the best way to go
the best way to go was to take here i
actually did check it
um because i wanted to know what would i
do the next time so if i'm actually
playing one of you guys on our twitter
yeah are we live do i see myself making
ugly faces
oh i'm back okay so the ugly faces work
maybe that was the trick
all right thank you ben i'll go attend
to chat
bye all right so i guess we figured that
was a problem the to youtube really
wanted to get my face doing a very ugly
face
so there you go you guys have it
hopefully tracy will make a clip out of
it and that will be permanently on
youtube
or anywhere else okay
um all right so
big thank you to ben simon for
helping out and tracy for fixing that
which i still don't know what went wrong
and tracy
i think you're speaking in a different
language i have no idea what is
auto optimizing i
all i know is how to rate books and
answer questions multiple choice
i don't know about streaming girl the
only thing i know is you get in you
change the
um the streaming key
you hit let's go live all right
maybe that's another reason why i don't
stream on my own
but alright so let's go ahead and i
really want to be able to address
what went wrong in this opening so
um i was talking about bishop d3 and i
believe that's where my face started
going
um kind of weird all right
so thank you for all of you who stayed
through this
lovely issue um
yeah that's all i know that's all i know
to do take exams
read books okay so i was talking about
how h6 is something that could
potentially
be um looked onto
because um you generally want to
exchange that
and you would get bishop on e4 and it
looks a little
um um it looks a little
a little unorthodox i want to say but
the problem is that well you do knight
f3 and then you're gonna just castle you
put your queen on d3 and
seems to be going great um
so one thing that we could definitely
talk about is this idea with c5 because
then take
you could easily enter the end game as
well i
wouldn't to be honest taking with the
knight seems to be okay
just castling seems to be all right so
there are a lot of different things
but um castling bishop c5 maybe
maybe might be a little too much but you
see this bishop is really stuck
so i do like that
oh why knight f3 was a mistake no i'm
going back to talk about why knight f3
was not the most accurate move but life
after is still very doable but the thing
is when knight f3
um h6 and then after take take
i should have taken and then played
bishop d3 to be able to still recreate
that idea
but what i did was i
didn't do the last take and i played
bishop to d3
and i gave her the chance to go knight
d5 so she first played bishop e7
now look if i were to take the bishop
tanks and
my d4 pawn is being a little bit more
under pressure i still have this idea
that bishop e4 and all c5
but you see this bishop was supposed to
be on f8 now on f6 it's going to be more
unpleasant for me
so um in the game i decided to go
queenie too
my idea was if you take it i can take
bishop or queen
and i'm activating everything but the
problem with queen e2
was a nice d5 and i'm just going to show
you a few more moves because
we already covered this a little bit on
the latest video on twitch well
the sunday um dorsetalia swap
so i covered that a little bit in there
all right so the problem is that right
now i wish i really had like a dark
squared bishop here
but i don't so i have to start covering
up
so i went for g3
and after c3 after g3 then
i made the mistake of doing long cancel
so long castle was a pretty bad
move it's not a blunder as as it is a3
is better to stop
knight b4s and then you could consider
something with long castle movie knight
e5 that would be much more interesting
but after castle knight before now
white to move what do you think we
should do
okay so i see a lot of kingy ones i see
some bishop c4s
mixed with praying so i think um
i went to bishop c4 and that was a
mistake i should have went king b1
or i think just there's an idea with
knight c32 i don't exactly love knight
c3 so kb1
should happen take take and
then you are well your opponent has two
bishops but that's what you should do
because it's between bad and worse then
you can try to just
bring like a rookie one then start maybe
95 and you're doing stuff in the center
it's pretty good
however after bishop c4 can you tell me
what is wrong with bishop c4
yeah i see people are beginning to
realize why this is a little painful
um e5 exactly
the problem is if you were to take it
which you should that's the last like
that's the last hope
now um simply knight can go to b4
and i mean it's still playable
because white still has a pretty decent
center but the problem is that
um black also has a lot of activity
which are not really ideal so
yep that's not exactly what i was hoping
for
and i made the mistake of giving my
opponents too much chance
and i went for a bishop b3 after that
she played a5 a4 coming up and i'm a
little busted because i can't exactly do
a3 either there's a four
so i decided to i calculated this line
and i thought if i do queen takes b5
a4 if bishop c4 there's bishop a6 so i
can't do that
so queen takes b4 a queen takes b5 a4
then i do a then i'm sorry then i take
this
c6 come back queen to c4
and then a3
to try and like pin this lots and lots
of arrows
i know right lots of arrows giving you a
small headache i know
but to to make it a little easier queen
is on c4 in the end
in the position that i'm talking about
that is still on b4 my bishop is gone
but it's on a4
rook is taking on a4 and i have this a3
and i'm pinning the knight
so i know it seemed a little confusing
but
or maybe a lot confusing but that's
something that you could easily go for
queen on c4 knight on b4 rook on e4 and
i saw that then i was like huh
that could work because i have this i'm
pinning it
and i made the mistake that i went down
that rabbit hole
and we ended up in this position as just
as just i discussed and the problem was
that i completely missed the move of
queen d5
to be completely fair bishop a6 or queen
a5 are also
much better for black but the simplest
one is going to d5
and now i have to move my knight which
results in
this rook going free and this knight
point
so i played queen b3 i was a little
hopeful maybe you take it
and i survived but my opponent
was a very strong player and she did not
she just played rocket eight and after
this is actually a little sad
i'm just going to stop here and for the
rest of the game i will definitely share
um the link we have on study for lyches
and also you can also watch
the sunday lesson for practical chess
um on understanding practical chess
on twitch that i was being talia anyway
so this was a very painful game now i'm
going to show you
two or three super quick sweet games
and that is another reason that i asked
ben
to share a little bit about
this scotch gambit
that i've done before but that's that's
the reason why i want you guys to know
scotch and i want you guys to play it
um not religiously i don't play it
religiously
but have an understanding of what you're
trying to do what is your opponent
trying to do
oh steve i was very sad too guys i was
very sad after this
but i mean i had another game so i can't
just you couldn't just sit there and cry
and
not not be there for your team so
i'm glad that i only lost one game out
of five and that was everybody loses
all right so bishop c5
knight b3 this is one of the lines i
think if you are a scotch player you
should know
if you play as black you should
definitely know because when you don't
know
this happens to you what's happened to
my opponent knight f6
queen e2 i already mentioned this
briefly in other youtube
videos which the links will be also
posted here and also
a lot when we play the viewers i talk
about how bishop comes to go to e3 f3 so
no knight g4s
and i'm preparing for g4 and long castle
so that's kind of the general idea of
bishop e3 f3
long castle g4 attack attack attack so
as black you have multiple choices one
of your choices is this don't do knight
f6 too fast play d6 get the bishop out
get the queen out too long castle
another choice is do knight e7
f castle f5 another choice knights e7
d6 f5 with castle another choice is
knight f6
and you still either do long castle
or when you do knight f6 you do short
castle but you
do not play h6 don't play h6 if you're
in a short castle
all right so that was a lot of
information i just covered for what
black should do
but because i'm not going in too into to
deepen them
i'm just briefly mentioning them i'm
just telling you the options that you
should be aware of both as white and as
black
okay so oh that was a mouthful
so in the game i found that knight f6
queenie two queen e7
why two what do you think we should play
and i agree um so
one thing that i learned is that so if
you even if you don't play e4 or even if
you don't play e5
you can still learn a little bit about
the
pawn structures because there are a lot
of um
creative pawn structures that you might
see for example cosplay pawn structure i
don't play it as white
i rarely play it as black but i kind of
know how
to play it i kind of know what is the
idea of white
i know about the minority pawn attacks i
know but like i have to
get my bishop to f5 and exchange that i
kind of have like a general
understanding of what is expected
so scotch has a lot of those type of
pawn structures as well
not in this specific line but that is
why we shouldn't
um just see i don't play sketch i don't
need to know
all right so yes mission g5
and uh there was a question on why not
h6 because if you were to play h6 let's
say on the right knight play h6
i get my bishop out your castle f3 d6
long castle now this h6 is a target when
i play g5
this is a serious problem but if your
pawn was on h7
i would still have to play
i would still have to spend more time
and energy
trying to open up your king that is kind
of why
um you shouldn't do this h6
all right um so however my opponent
simply played queen e7 bishop g5
as chad mentioned h6 now
why to move what should we do oh my god
did my internet die again
they say internet's not dead ah that's
not that
but there seemed to be a lag
or not oh boy
i'm gonna have to text ben again
oh my paranoid never mind tracy
confirmed it's good
okay so i'm just being a tiny bit
paranoid
okay um so ah i'm seeing
there is a lot of mentions of retreating
but we don't need to do that we don't
need to go to h4f4 you guys are
forgetting
knight d5 let's go after the bigger fish
and in the game my opponent played
whoops queen e5
which led land gave me the opportunity
to just take over here
and just long castle now this is a super
weak thing for me to go after
and my knight has a super knight d6 i
simply went to queen f3
as i also mentioned in the twitch f4 is
the better way to go
queen e6 and you would then simply play
queenie one
actually let me show it why am i
arrowing it up f4
queen e6 queen e1 with the idea of
bishop c4 and
some nasty night moves exactly boom
um so i went for queen f3 because it
looked the
healthiest way and now knight f6 is
coming up so my opponent fight this
check
and play bishop g4 one thing that i
really did want to mention to you guys
as well
is that queen f3 necessarily is not
the brightest move but it does give my
opponent a chance to mess it up
and specifically because i was higher
rated
and i kind of wanted to give my opponent
a chance to mess it up in a worse
position
that's kind of why i did this queen f3
because i wanted to
allow this bishop g4 and yes i could
simply take and just take over here
and that is great um i
kind of decided to keep the the knights
keep the queens on the board
and i just ate that guy with the knights
and just put the knight on e3
and there is only like three more moves
so i'm going to show you guys before we
move to the next one
95.5 take over here
take take and this was also and as my
opponent resigned here which was a
um pleasant for me uh i got to sleep
after this
because it was uh it was still very
early in the morning
yeah so um i was very
glad with this game but i showed you
this game because i wanted to emphasize
on the scotch of it
and so you guys will have more material
to look on for
the youtube channel some of the scotch
videos that i've done ooh
gmp shoes behind the window looking in
yeah it was a nice game this one is also
a very short and sweet game and i do
want to
very briefly mention it so i'm gonna put
a timer for less than five minutes to go
over this game
and that is why i might not exactly ask
too many questions because
i already did talk about this game on
our twitter channel and i don't want to
repeat myself
too much a little bit repetition is good
so
with in karakan i realized that i don't
like playing knight c3 i realized that
years ago because of this weird g6
because i really want
my knight to whoops no nothing i would
really want to have the c3 against this
weird g6 so i just kind of blind your
bishop immediately
so that is why i went for a knight d2 g6
c3 boom well i didn't exactly know the
theory behind it but i knew that i want
that
bishop to be blinded so c3 bishop g7
bishop d3 normal stuff and i
also talked about this a little bit
before with another chess player on
why i kind of love this f4 idea and
well i've always been very great at
active play so if you give me a super
positional play that i really need to
calculate and find like the only moves
to survive
well that's also possible but i'm not
going to enjoy it
so when i'm playing active chess i play
my best
tips for you guys when we play online
don't let me play active chess
so um after this
knight h6 i kind of knew how this game
was gonna go
at some point you're gonna take this at
some point you're gonna put that knight
on f5
so i was like if you're gonna do knight
to five i might as well have my pawns on
f4 and then throw in a g4 and poke your
knight and then do it f5
and keep it active so to be fair i also
did that because i was like 200 points a
little over 200 points
um better well
higher rated than my opponent i don't
really want to say better because rating
doesn't
i mean rating just because you're high
rated you don't exactly
mean you are going to
win it so all right so f4
take ha exchange friends yeah peter you
saw how i played an exchange friends
french so uh-oh giving up all my secrets
all right so yes exquisite probably
that probably would be unpleasant for me
as well
so we got into this position and i'm
like okay
i don't like this knight here so i'm
gonna kick it
i'm kicking the knight kicking the
knight still g4 coming up
and the only thing that i did actually
calculate was because my queen is
defending each one if you were to play
h5 i would play g4
oops take take and my queen is defending
my rook so your knights will have to
move
so if h5 g4 take take
and my queen is defending my rook so
that was kind of the only thing that i
did calculate and my opponents went
queen eight five
simple idea when i eat my palm bishop d2
no thank you la casta
and here she played short castle which i
think was suicide to be honest
i think 97 should have been better even
g4 knight d6 it's still
quite unpleasant because your king is
still in the center and your knight here
was very misplaced
but it's still i mean the game still
goes on i mean still very painful but
still goes on
however when you did short castle after
g4
96 take take f5 now i want to do f6
and i am um seriously blinding your
bishop
not just like a c3 move like a real
blinding that the
bishop goes to h8 i never see the seize
the sun type of deal
so my clients went 97 for the same
purpose of wanting to play f6
g5 now f6 coming up right um she
she kind of um i think she kind of gave
up and
she just allowed me to make this battery
and she immediately resigned after
so oh i actually did it in less than
five minutes so my point of showing you
this game was that even if you don't
know the opening
at move four it doesn't mean that you
need to know opening to win the game as
long as you kind of have a general
understanding of your chess
and the general understanding of what's
to come for this position so this idea
with bishop d3
it was very useful this idea that f4 and
g4 when the knight was coming to f5 was
very useful
so that's something you guys could
definitely do
all right so this game um i went and i
looked at the opening
so oh we are
reaching century mark as tracy is saying
that is great
thank you tracy for keeping tabs
especially with
the internet crash slash crush that i
had
yay
um steve i think that's also
cool but whoa i
i've never thought of myself as
bloodthirsty more like
king thirsty or peace hungry but okay
all right so um
to be fair i did um i kind of knew what
i was doing in the opening
uh because i mean i played this opening
regularly
but b5 was a little bit unusual to me
because
after b5 i well you want to play b4 and
i have to move the knight and
you want to eat my paw so i don't
exactly love this idea
so i immediately thought about a3
however a3 is not the right move so can
you guys tell me what is the best move
here
so way too mu what's the bus
oh the cat is making an appearance is he
coming in
oh i see a knight b5 that's a bishop f3
f3 not exactly oh nobody's actually
saying this move
ha ha interesting
no i did a three in the game anonymous
the best one is actually knight takes c6
very surprisingly
because if you were to take d-take c6
now i have
f4 and
now if bishop goes to b7 the thing is if
you were to play this b4 now i just do
knight to a4
a lot of stuff happening on b6 but if
you also were to take knight take c4
bishop f3
this is also another thing that's
happening f5 now bishop d4 now my
bishops are monster
i'm also going to take here play a 5 so
that's something that you could
definitely consider but in the game
uh i didn't i was just like oh a b4 is
coming i gotta play a3
and also also if bishop goes to b7 you
just have this e5
and this is another very pleasant
position
um i mean to be fair bishop c5s could
come up but
now this bishop is kind of bad this
bishop gets d to go to d3 i get to play
this on f5's i
love it um another thing to do
is this idea with if e5 but i could
simply take
take and kingish one save my bishop and
save my queen
and then go to g3 and just start poking
around a little
so yeah this was something that i
actually did not know before the game
and i've actually learned this since
that sunday
so well to be fair i kind of
knew of it but i didn't exactly know it
so keep that in mind if you are going to
play these lines
uh make sure you are comfortable with
this okay
all right um
any questions on this before i move to
the game
all right so no questions
all right chad seems to be very happy
with this line all right let's move on
so i went for a3 to stop b4
but then the problem was bishop b7 and i
should have again taken it and played
queen d3
but it was too late at this point i
played f4
and i was a humongous mistake
because now my opponent
what do you think black can do actually
no
no so
you guys see that this knight d4 is kind
of um pen dried
and you see that bishop on e3 is
defenseless right so if
black would magically get another piece
to come cover up an attack on d4
that's another thing that could
definitely be a little painful for me
right so
uh-huh
yep queen b6 you guys got this whoop
this is what my opponent's in the game
but queen v6 and i would have had a very
unpleasant game definitely
definitely unpleasant least of all
because now if i were to take
it well you just simply take over here
take that
you take over here i take back
take king h1 rook g8 that's going to be
very painful
even if i didn't um even if i just play
the king ishwanta i'm still attacking
that's still rookie
if take the funny thing is that you can
even do like knight g3
and have a much better position or you
could also just
you know take over here which you want
to do bishop g2 checkmate
so i can't save my bishop and i have to
do like a
knight e4 you take that queen takes e2
so
my queen is defending it and attacking
it queen goes to b7 and this is
still going to be extremely painful
so back here
my opponent missed it she was 2100 she
missed it
take take and she played knight e4
um i decided to simply just exchange
this because
this um i just wanted to try and create
some
type of activity um
and then i could just do c3 defend it
but well i like playing active so i went
and played c4
oh god uh here she should have again
played queen v6 to
bring more pressure but she simply took
now
why did you move what do you think you
should do
um gg
i i'm i'm good at chess i never said i'm
not good at chess i say that
i have a different style many people
might
enjoy calculating very deep lines and
might be
very proud that they can calculate 10
moves in different like in three
different lines and still do that and
they enjoy it
i don't so i try to play more practical
chess which
makes me just kind of um i get a little
busted here and there because i
sometimes you do need to absolutely
calculate and
know the exact move sometimes you don't
so
and also yes i'm also a more serious
student
studying for to be a doctor so that's
also another part of it
um okay so
to be fair yes rook c1 is the best move
and no i did not do it because roxy1 i
actually don't know why i think i was
i'm unhappy with the move d5 and i
didn't really
like to get into this position i wanted
to keep my pawn
on um the different pawn structure
so i just went for take here and
i thought that okay well if you take
queen takes that's great this is also a
weak pawn attacking bishop
but black knight queen b6 well now i
have a
only move because you are going to take
my bishop and i can't
exactly take it because you take and
you're attacking my
bishop over here and my king over here
so i have to play bishop f2 now
she should have taken queen takes b2 and
after queen b2
as white i think i should have done
something with like bishop b2
to cover up a little and it's still very
unpleasant
it's not lost or anything but white
would
i would not really like it
she played queen c6 now the idea of
queen c6
is that it's attacking g2 and
i can't exactly defend it because if i
were to play that queen to g4
you can take over here and pick up my
bishop so
now why does the move what do you think
we should do and this is one of the
moments that i actually did calculate
um like for five ish moves and i was
quite happy with
how the position would turn out and i
went for it
so well technically before i play visual
f2 i consider this
i see bishop d3 i see
taking on c5s hold on hold on exquisite
if you were to take it
take rook c2 your bishop is falling
careful
we don't want to lose our bishops i did
not place the votes
i did not place the go to this gambit i
saved this position i won the game but
this position is actually good position
just have to be very
precise with what you do and rook c1 was
the way to go
because you're defending your bishop and
if bishop whoops and if bishop takes g2
now i get to take over here if he were
to take bishop f1 bishop takes f1
and my rook is defending my bishop so
that was a very good game that was a
very
i was very proud of this part of the
calculation and i also went a little
deeper if you take
i just take this voila um
and also if you played bishop h3 another
great way to continue is rook f2 i was
very proud of this move
because rook f2 you see you might rip us
against your queen
and i considered queen f3 briefly but
takes rook f2 and
still the same thing and
that's why we don't exactly want to go
for it if i'm going to play recruiter i
might as well play rook after
right now right so rook f2 ash in the
game she played queen take c5
and now uh you have a chance between
bishop e6 and bishop f1
which one do you think you should do
yourself yes i did
because i found what i should have done
in the opening
and i really wanted to share that with
the chat because the opening part was
kind of what
got me busted in the game so i thought
it really did deserve a chance to go
over the opening a little bit more
deeper
so i would strongly recommend that if
you didn't
get to check the opening part please do
because i'm very proud of that part so
why to what do you think we should go
for
ah i see people are falling into my trap
no problem of bishop f1 is bishop g4
guys
this is still better for white but the
problem is bishop g4
and you can't really move your queen
because your rook falls
and you can't really eat that because
your queen falls so be very careful
to be honest in the game i almost played
bishop that one i remember i had this on
a cell bishop defusing woof
and i just immediately took on e6 in the
game she took here
and i just ate that pawn and the rest of
the game is on twitch and also
i will share this link with you guys so
you can take a quick look and the rest
of it was just
tech technique you come over you change
the rook
you um keep the file and you start
pushing your pawns
if your opponent is happy with an idea
such as g5 you take it away
if your opponent still is happy with
that idea such as g5 you come to queen
c2 so if g5 you have a bunch of poking
to do
the shift d5 you attack there's two guys
whoops no bishop d5 queen d3
eats with check give another check no
chance of running away
put that king in a bag back back
box and start pushing your pawns
that was kind of my strategy of um
really just winning a clean game all
right
so this is actually another game that i
do want to talk about
um so this is uh a rule of this game
that i played i i am going to try and do
a small segment on rue lopez uh as black
at least i i did i think i did it as
white with queenie two lines because i
thought they were very interesting but
i play this weird knight d7 whoops 97
d6 and g 6 ideas as
white as black so i think you should
definitely have a small understanding of
what are these moves at least if you
play it as white if you play it as black
i think
this is worth a try because it really
does confuse the opponent
and my opponent was not lower not lower
not
like a beginner she was a great chess
player she was playing for
one of she was a representative of one
of the european um
clubs so she knew what she was doing um
she played after g6 so
one of the lines that's a little
annoying is early d4 another line is
like c3 with idea d4
whatever you do you should get these d4
in at some point
so she played castle bishop g5
c3 i started to i decided to poke this
bishop
a little away and now after h3 i think
h3 was to
stop um bishop to g4 i
am not entirely sure if that's necessary
because if you played d4
then yes there is bishop g4 and but
there's d5 as well
so i don't really think i wouldn't
really play this bishop g4 so
tip guys you don't really need to play
this h3 when you are going to play
ideas with d5 anyways after h3 i simply
played knight f6
get the nightstands out another thing is
that in this type of closed uh
roomba business this knife on f4 will be
very cool
so in the game she went d4 castle my
point was if you were to take over here
now i can just take with the knight and
if you were to exchange these queens
yeah this is an interesting end game but
my knife is already attacking your pawn
my rook is already taking over this file
and i really do like it
i agree people trying to get away from
berlin
started to look at this g6 and d6 ideas
uh in the game opponents went rookie one
depending upon
logical um so black to move what do you
think we should do
uh at this position one of the things
that you should definitely keep in mind
is the idea of if white takes and
when white wants to take so if white
does want to take over here the problem
is with bishop e3 and bishop c5s
that's another thing to at least keep in
mind
um another part is with
d takes e5 or d5 so these are the two
main spawn structures to keep in mind so
whatever you do
you should have that you should kind of
be ready for it
oh actually that is true exquisite i do
i'll show you how this game was very
similar to
um king's gambit as well g5
bishop went to v3 i was still a little
concerned about this
i could have simply played bishop c7
bishop b7 sorry
but to me the move queen e7 was more
natural
if he were to take it i could just take
back with the pawn over the knight and i
don't really have to worry about these
moves and i can start
doing stuff in the queen side and when i
actually do get to do the lopez segment
for a little bit
this is something that i will definitely
talk about more because i have so
many games in this um in this game my
opponent
went for d5 makes sense right poking the
knights you gotta move the knight
uh knight goes to a5 bishop c2
now one thing that i kind of regret and
i wish i might have done
is this idea with knight c4 knight b6
because this knight on b6 is makes much
more sense than on a5
because the knight on a5 if your knight
is on b6 it's also stopping the ideas
with a4
so i think knight a4 knight c4 is
definitely worth the idea ooh
c5 is interesting but c5 um
the problem is that you have to be very
careful when you do stuff in the queen
side because
your main game is going to be in the
king side so you kind of have to find
that fine balance
uh simon i don't blame you i don't
actually play kings in the end that
often as black
but i do play this drill up this pretty
much very regularly if not every game at
least every other game
so i went for knight h5 to be fair the
best move is c6
if you played a4 now i just have to do
like bishop b7
and kind of keep it like this but to me
this was very boring
so i went for knight to h5
my idea is f5 my opponent went bishop g5
f6 bishop h4 which much for whoops
was a mistake can you tell me what's why
well what do you want to do as black
i'm glad tracy remembers this rule opus
i have talked about this type of
positions a lot
and not i don't think this game has ever
been repeated for me
but yeah so that's the fine thing you
have to figure out when to play this g5
i was trying to figure out how to play
f5 how to play g5
and in the game i played queen f7
because i really wanted to do this f5 i
have this pawn back on f5
but queen f7 was not the most accurate
thing to do g5
is bishop g3 take take then g4
and now you want to take over here and
take your bishop gets all
freed up and these pawns are miserable
that's pretty great
right oh right sophia yeah you want to
push the bishop away
however one thing that i didn't like was
if i attack your bishop and if you move
your knight let's say you play knight d2
and you're attacking my knight what do i
do with that queen f7
and then you can just go bishop g3 take
take and
now i can't really i don't really want
to play this f5 i also don't really want
to play this g4 because it all can all
get tangled up
so i was really trying my best not to
give my opponent too much chance and i
actually definitely did i went to queen
f7
and she got a four aprons by itself not
a big deal because i can simply play
vision b7
and it's not a big deal but i just gave
like a tiny bit of room for my opponent
to do what she wants
uh she played knight d2 now i really did
want to play this g5 again
but to similar problems g5 bishop g3
even if i were to take take and play g4
you can still just play knight h4
ah knight is four if take you can just
play like b4
now i have to figure out what to do with
this knight so i didn't really want to
get into this uncertain positions and
so we went back to
here and my general idea is i want to
get this at five
and i want to be able to take it back
with the pawn so in the game i went for
h6
my idea was that i want to do
um f5 and if you take i take the clone i
didn't want to deal with knight g5s
also also h6 is doable
but before knight c4 take take
and here she made this inaccuracy my
opponents played queenie two and picked
this guy up with the knight with the
queen
she should have played knight to d2 and
went for it with the knights
that was where she went wrong because if
knight d2 and now the queen is also
keeping an eye on this light you could
also try to do like an f3
get your bishop back to the game so this
would have been the better way to go but
she played queen to
e2 um
and play and she went after c4
now i i thought this is my chance i can
do either c6 or f5
and i found c6 to be profoundly boring
i apologize for those of you who like c6
c6
is the best move but it did not really
go well with me
but this should have it should have no
questions asked there because if you
were to take it now take
um take and now i also have this g5 and
f5 and this ones are
all getting um rallied up yes clubs
can't invite anybody that is true
so c6 would be the best way to go i went
and i played
f5 she took i took
i should have played knight f4 take and
then bishop takes f5
take over here take over there and start
pushing e4
so i also made a small another
inaccuracy
[Music]
is what uh peter what do you mean it's
just a name
i don't represent england but i could
play for their team
same way when i was in iran i was
representing um
i was playing for switzerland team for
their league it's
it's it's i don't know enough soccer but
i'm sure that they can
get players who are not born in that
country or play for that country to play
for them
seasonally now um gtx m5 queen takes c4
and here i actually did
an interesting move of e4 so my idea was
i really really really really really
wanted to attack this bishop somehow so
i could do like an f4
f3 but i can't do that right now so i
went for knight
f4 and my idea was simple i want to
provoke you
to give me the square by eating this too
in the game she should have played
bishop g3 which she didn't
and this would have been more unpleasant
if i'm being completely honest white
would have advantage here
i would do bishop e5 and then take
take he would get rid of this strong
night of mine
and do like a knight e6 and this would
be better for white
not winning but definitely better so
knight f4 was provocative because we
were also
i think in time trouble uh at least time
pressure it's it's
like i wasn't playing on like two
seconds but i did also actually i was in
this game
this game was the game that i was
playing on 10 seconds most of the game
huh
oops yeah so she played bishop v3
defending it but
she gave me this lovely square and she
also gave me queenish five
i appreciated this both of these idea
and i just went for knight d3
uh quinash five would have been stronger
because after bishop g3 i would have
this super cool tactic
but over the board i did not see it this
is something that i looked at after the
game
um so yeah
i went for knight d3 because it looks
like a cool
outpost attacking the rook 2 rookie 3
i went for rook c8 um i should have went
for
this move uh that's a little bit crazy
bishop b5
if you take it upon i take that and then
your rook and your queens are under
attack which is
super cool but what if the knight takes
you take and then the queen takes i
didn't really
know what was i doing in this position
so i didn't really go for it
but this would have been a super cool
tactical position
i simply went for rook c8 defending this
pawn
and i didn't really want to deal with
knight e6 she went knight e6
i didn't want whoops i had to whoa
that's not a move that you would do
i kind of had to deal with not losing
this bishop so i went for bishop e5
whoops also stopping knight rook g3s
she does hold advantage here she played
f4 which
f4 was the mistake because she should
have taken over here
and she should have let this strong
knight show off
she didn't that was a mistake um so
after bishop b5 she played f4 and i
saved my knight and she just turned a
check
and now it was another cool thing
knight g6 trapping your bishop um
she should have played queen takes e4
but she didn't especially because you're
built in super time trouble and i'm
attacking bunch of stuff at once
um she played rook takes g6 queen takes
g6 and now see your cheat's coming up
and you are gonna feel
that's tornado she went tricky one and i
just played rook g8 simple moves
again q5 is the most accurate one or c5
is another cool move but routine
seems to just be good enough practical
chess guys practical chess
and here i was like you know what i
really don't want to lose my pawns
i'm just going to defend my pawns and it
was just good enough
it wasn't the best move the best move
would be to take over here
but i didn't want to risk it i wanted to
keep my position safe
i wanted to hold my advantage and she
started messing it up even though her
position is like -4
already she played like c4 and i just
went for c6
and she took over here she thought b5
was working but it wasn't
um because again i have this like check
and put the bishop back here as well
and i just i remember i was in time
travel and i just wanted to not think
about checks and i just played
king h7 no problem and uh she played
rocket one and then she resigned because
she just gave up rook but anyways this
is like already plus 10 for me
so that wasn't the problem the problem
was that
practical chess practical just is very
important you see i i had a worse
position
that knight 96 was horrifying for me and
as white i think white's biggest mistake
was not taking rook takes d3 because
if you were to think about this position
logically why it's better
right well it has more material well it
has better night i have a good night too
but my king is a little weird my pieces
are not as coordinated but if you give
me like five moves
i'm gonna fix it so you have to play
very fast and as
white this is the most annoying piece
for black so you should take it
get rid of it you still hold the
advantage all my pawns are looking weird
this knight is super cool now this
bishop is also strong
because i can't really take it you know
e7s are coming up
so yeah i think that was white's biggest
mistake but besides that i think that
the games were
um quite pleasant yeah i also had a very
nice experience playing for european
clubs cup hopefully next year um
after we're all vaccinated the we can
actually go to monte carlo and play it
but
anyways this is my last stream of 2020
unless something drastically changes the
it's the last scheduled streaming of
2020
so i hope you guys will enjoy it
and make sure to check out the other
videos that i've done on scotch on the
youtube channel
and there will be a lopez coming up um
in 2021 but oh my god i can't say 20 21.
it's coming up anyways so happy holidays
and i'll see you next year have a great
rest of your year